- Hey guys, on episode five of Trash Talk,
you're going to see me yelling at deer.
Hey Bambi, you're not gettin' it bro!
talking to a wise old man
- That's why I'm selling it
- That's right
(laughing)
Buying expensive lemonade
and finding some rad-ass shit.
(hip hop music)
♪ Now the future is yours, go ♪
- Trash Talk episode five,
in the Lincoln Tunnel.
Wasn't supposed to be in
this tunnel but D-Rock
forgot the batteries so we
had to go to the office.
That's D-Rock running.
So a little bit of a later
start to the town-wide sale
and that's the big thing.
You want to Google search
'town wide garage sale',
'cause we can get 50 or 60 or 30 or 50
or 100 sales together in the same area.
You get way more efficient than
driving 10, 15, 20 minutes to every sale.
One of the things,
when you see 4 or 5
different town wide sales,
it's cool to check, Google the town
and check the median income.
'Cause when the median income is higher,
and there's more affluence in the town,
it's more likely that
they're going to sell off
more expensive stuff
than let's say, a town
that's more middle class
or lower middle class than let's say,
upper middle class or extremely affluent.
And so, a couple little
tricks here to start
episode five.
Let's get into it now!
(electronic dance music)
(phone ringing)
- [Mike] What's up?
- Good news.
- [Mike] Yeah?
- We're out and about.
- [Mike] Oh yeah?
- Yeah, you have Instagram?
- [Mike] Nah.
(phone ringing)
- [AJ] What's up?
- I like your prediction on Instagram.
- [AJ] You like it?
- I've never found a Starbucks rare mug.
(phone ringing)
- [Brandon] Hello
- I'm out hunting.
(Brandon laughing)
- I can't wait.
The Zelda game was so cool.
- How crazy was that?
- [Lou] Yo
- [Gary] Yo, getting close.
- [Lou] I just pulled up to the house.
- How's the action look?
- [Lou] A few tables,
someone just pulled up
going in, they look like
they got real skills.
- Somebody pulled up to the garage sale
and you feel like they have skills?
- [Lou] Yeah, they know
what they're doing!
- God damn it.
If that guy walks out with
a Nintendo in package,
I'm gonna kill D-Rock.
But do somethin', Lou!
You're like Robin out here!
When Batman's stuck 'cause
The Joker screwed up,
you gotta go do somethin' about it!
(sighs)
(laughs) I really think I'm a good driver,
'cause garage sales, you
have to be so observant.
Plus I'm from the old
school, pre-internet.
Pre-smart phone.
I was just lookin' for signs.
Wahh!
Practice the K turn.
When you first get your license,
and it's for this reason.
I was a K turn champion.
I like what I'm seein'.
This Budweiser sign's a fortune.
- [Man] Does it have a
year on it or anything?
- [Gary] That's a nice one, though.
What's 10?
10 for it.
That's cheap.
Would you consider five for this?
- [Resident] No.
- What else you seein', anything?
(inaudible)
Nah, Trolls suck.
(spit) One of the things
that people don't realize is
silence is a huge negotiation tactic.
- Tash!
Shh!
- If you now notice back to last week
and now this week right off the bat,
I just go silent.
And in that silence, they
have to now start thinking,
and they have to decide if
they want to get rid of it.
All right I think we go.
(birds chirping)
I mean this Budweiser thing is
eight?
- [Resident] Yeah.
- All right, Lou,
eight is worth it.
And I was gonna go seven there,
but then I was just like,
I kinda like the guy.
- [Resident] Cool beer light.
- It's rad.
- [Resident] But I gotta
get rid of some stuff,
I can't keep everything!
- Can't keep everything, right?
(laughs)
There you go.
Five.
Six, seven, eight.
Have a great day, guys, take care.
Stay well.
Come on, Lou.
All right, right off the bat,
we got them.
We paid, hold up, Lou.
Hold it up.
We paid eight for this
vintage Budweiser light,
which I'm feelin' real,
real, real good about.
Right off the bat we got a big one!
That's the kind of thing you
put on Facebook Marketplace
or on Craigslist, and wait
for a collector to come
(cash register)
on Craigslist,
and go 50 to 75,
I mean, that's a $50 dollar
profit right off the bat.
(twinkle)
Things feel very overpriced,
but one of the things that
tend to not be overpriced
is stuffed animals.
But,
they're pretty overpriced here.
Hershey Kisses does well.
The Hello Kitty's legit.
Bear.
Hershey Kisses collectible but
I don't know.
(buzz)
How are you?
- How are you?
- Good, hi.
Old Yankee mugs.
'96 Yankee mugs.
$4 bucks, everything is
expensive as shit here!
Now, I just noticed they negotiated, so
are these four each?
- [Resident] I could do
two for five if you want.
(cash register)
- Two for five, okay.
Thank you, thanks so much.
Take care, guys, bye bye.
- [Resident] Thanks.
- All right, just picked up
this 1996 vintage Yankees mug.
World Champs, picked
up two for five bucks.
She wanted four each.
She didn't get it!
She got five for two.
$2.50 a pop, let's look 'em up.
(electronic beep)
By the way, they answer a couple questions
that have been poppin' up.
When I'm out in the trenches out there,
I'm searchin' my phone for eBay auctions
through the eBay app.
I'm looking at completed auctions
and completed and sold.
Those are two filters that you can create
when you search on eBay.
♪ I ain't got time ♪
- [Gary] Couldn't find the Yankee mugs.
On to the next sale.
Oh, cookies!
Hello.
Another strike out.
Strike one, strike two, strike three.
- [Man] Wow.
- Wow!
- [Gary] How are you?
- [Resident] Morning.
- [Gary] Good, morning.
I will take this South
Park thing for sure.
- [Resident] South Park fan?
- I definitely feel good
about my South Park buy.
I'm dying to see what this
(cash register)
South Park stuff is, I think I stole it.
Seven South Park plush for five bucks.
(laughs)
Look at the deer, look at the deer!
This deer is trying to get my money!
Hey, Bambi!
Hey, Bambi, you're not gettin' it, bro!
I'm gettin' it, Bambi!
I'm gettin' it!
That's right, you better run!
(laughs)
This one feels like a moving sale.
This one, okay get in here.
Inside.
- [Man] The house.
- Lou, turn off the car.
(laughs)
Let's do it in film time.
- This whole section here
is two dollars right off this line.
- This is a pleasure!
- How are you?
- I'm great, yourself?
- Good, very good.
- Wow, I'm out hustlin' early
this morning!
- I love it.
I'm impressed, brother.
- I'm from Westchester.
But we don't have
- I know you don't, I know.
- Mug Life, all day.
- Thank you, brother.
- [Resident] Can I get a photo?
- Sure.
- Thanks, good luck.
- Good luck.
- See ya, thank you.
- All $2 section, right here,
right up into the house.
Then there's a whole dollar
and five dollars right there.
- Thank you, brother.
These phones for two bucks are money.
Real.
- [Man] Hold the phones?
(laughs)
- Tell him to hold 'em for us.
(dog barking)
Look who's carrying.
Boo.
Booo.
Here you go.
- [Resident] Thank you.
(cash register)
- Thank you, brother.
- I was like, I gotta stop,
I turn around for a second.
(cash register)
I do this shit on eBay.
And mugs are great, how do
I scale something like this?
What do I gotta do,
because I'm by myself.
I mean, I could do Hot Wheels.
I could do a mug here.
I mean between my time,
my effort, my energy,
I'm online two hours a day.
- It's, it's hard to scale,
unless you're buying super bulk from Chi-,
this is a 101.
- Yeah.
- This is the one that gets you from
this is the one that can get you,
first of all, the way to
scale is to buy everything.
You and I
- And fill up my house?
- And fill up your house!
- And fill up my house.
- And then hire five
dollar, six dollar hour
immigrants, kids,
but we're being very choosey right now.
But everything there that was,
like the phone we just bought from AT&T,
that's $20 bucks!
We paid $2.
I normally don't buy that.
Last episode, I was very selective
to the things I want.
I'm just trying to teach people.
- Yeah, yeah.
- This house right here and
there's $400 dollars to be made.
- Right.
- But you have to fly every fuckin' thing!
- I know!
But then I'm sittin' there,
I gotta take pictures,
- I got it
- Post it, I don't mind
- Something that doesn't sell.
- I don't mind shipping and
costs, it's just I'm
gonna sit with this stuff.
- I get it.
- I just bought
some dreidel mugs and I was like,
you know.
- And to me,
the question becomes,
how much room do you have in your house?
And how much do you love it,
and how much do you need 30, 50, 100?
- I love the action, I love the action!
- Me too, me too, that's it.
- I mean,
- Do you have a basement, attic, garage?
- Yeah.
- Fill the fuckin' thing up!
- And my wife
- Will punch you in the face,
I get it!
(laughs)
- My wife will crush me!
- But that becomes the game.
- That's it.
- That's it, all right.
- All right, brother.
- Hey, thanks so much.
- Good luck, take care.
- Really a pleasure.
- My pleasure, stay well.
Go Jets!
I still think we missed out
on some rare gem already.
'Cause D-Rock forgot his
What about this grassy plain right here?
Feels under-utilized.
I feel like I should buy this and flip it.
All right.
What up?
Trash Talk people, we
picked up this phone.
This AT&T retro phone,
I picked it up because I
wanted to prove to people
there's a lot more money to be made.
I don't normally pick up
phones and electronics.
But they're such easy flips!
Paid $2 for this phone.
Whoa.
A lot of them sold.
Look at this.
(dance music)
Have a great day.
How much is Snoopy?
- [Resident] Four bucks.
- All right, we're a couple hours in
and we've gotten cold on these sales.
Which is not fun.
Time matters, D-Rock!
Hello!
How are you?
(inaudible)
I'm super well.
Video games, mugs,
- [Resident] Mugs.
- Mugs.
No video games?
- [Resident] No, she sold them I think,
just now.
- [D Rock] Oh, no.
- I wanna buy these
pencils and pencil fight.
I'll take this
for 25 cents.
(cash register)
You know about this, right?
Watch this.
Here we go.
Ready?
- What are we doing?
- I'll show you.
You hold it like this.
- Okay.
- All right.
I'll go first.
- [Video Game Voice] Game begin.
- You gonna break it?
- Mmhmm.
(explosion)
- [Resident] What are you doing?
- This is called pencil fighting,
it was huge in the '80s.
(smack)
(laughs)
- Does it normally take this long?
Yeah, he's doing it,
he's like cheating.
- What do you mean I'm cheating?
- He did do it that time? (laughs)
- Are you sure?
(snap)
(laughs)
(energetic video game music)
(snap)
- [Video Game Voice] Game Over.
- Champion.
(energetic video game music)
I see you, deer!
I know what you're trying to do!
You keep eatin', I keep hustlin'.
(laughs)
I love making deer my rival.
We're fairly cold.
Let's see if this mixes it up.
Have a great day, guys.
Take care, bye bye.
How much is this?
(cash register)
Take care.
- [Resident] Bye.
- Bye bye. Lou.
This is what's called
a Christmas cookie jar.
With an $80 retail sticker
that we bought for three bucks.
(laughs)
That hopefully goes for $20.
Just picked up this cookie jar
for three dollars.
Let's see what it's worth.
Have a great day, guys.
♪ Steady yawnin' ♪
♪ I wiped the cold up out my eyes ♪
- Hi, how are you?
Motherfucker.
I need a huge hit.
I need one huge hit to turn this show.
Have a great day.
(laughs)
That's awesome, man.
Real good.
I'm finding more fans than
fuckin' stuff I'm trying to find!
♪ Between the hours of
9 to 10 I can grind ♪
- It's cold.
- Thanks a lot, man.
- Take care, bud.
Go stay by your shirt!
K-Rock and that's D-Rock.
All right.
How much is the mug?
- [Resident] It's a dollar.
(laughs)
- [Gary] Thank you.
- [Female] Hello.
- [Gary] Yeah, I'm into mugs.
They're a buck a piece?
- [Resident] Yeah.
- [Gary] Okay.
- [Cartoon Voice] Five minutes later...
(cash register)
- Now that I've hit
the Mug Life, I can switch t-shirts.
(cash register)
And Winnie The Pooh is always in play.
And original Pound Puppy?
Let's go.
Picked this Disney mug,
Tree Of Life mug up for a dollar.
Look what it goes for.
(cash register)
Disney Park Tree Of Life
- [Man] Yep.
- Completed shows me
how many of that item have sold,
and how many have not sold.
Sold, when you add the sold part,
shows me what they've actually gone for.
So the screenshots that you're gonna see
edited here a lot of times
are coming right from my phone recordings
and it shows prior auctions,
what they've sold for.
And this,
18.
It's amazing.
I made $40 on that $2
bucks in two seconds.
How much are these?
- [Resident] The Skylanders?
- Mmhmm.
- [Resident] 10 dollars.
You're welcome.
- Would you take seven for the bag?
- [Man] Gary Vee!
- [Gary] What up, bro?
- [Man] What's up, man?
- How you doin'?
- [Man] Good, you're not filmin', right?
- I'm filmin'!
I'm always filmin'!
(laughs)
Have a good day!
- How's it goin', brother?
Let's go Jets, man.
- Let's go Jets is right.
- Awesome, man.
- Have a good time.
How you doin', good?
- Yeah, really good.
- Good, good.
Good, bro.
Paid seven for a huge collection
(cash register)
of Skylanders
(cash registers)
the bag itself is gonna be worth more.
There's two bags, Lou.
(cash registers)
There's like 30 figures.
I think we crushed this one.
How much are the stuffed animals?
- [Resident] Two dollars.
- [Gary] Popple!
- [Resident] That's an original Popple.
- [Gary] Is that what it is? That's cool.
I'll do these as well.
- [Resident] Okay then, two dollars.
- Two each.
Can I get the,
yeah.
You have another bag, potentially?
Thank you, take care.
- [Resident] You too, have a great day.
- Very accomplished man right now.
I'm on fire now.
Let's go!
All right, just went off.
Got seven stuffed animals for
or five for $7 dollars.
A Wrinkles,
an original Popple, give me that.
A Garfield original.
And a Cabbage Patch A
original '85.
Cabbage Patch B.
Original '85.
Oh yeah, Cabbage Patch accessories.
How much are the stuffed animals?
- [Resident] A dollar each.
- Great, thank you.
Thank you so much.
- [Resident] Thank you.
- [Gary] Have a great day.
- [Resident] You too.
- Picked up these two.
Two Ugly Dolls for a dollar each.
(cash register)
10 bucks.
Holy cow!
This one's
(cash register)
$23.
How much is the lamp?
- [Register] Oh, I'm not
sure I'm sellin' that one!
(laughs)
No!
- [Gary] You don't wanna sell it?
- [Resident] I don't wanna sell it!
(laughs)
- Is it, are you selling the lamp?
You shouldn't sell it if
you don't want to sell it.
You know what I mean?
- I know, but it's
(laughs)
- Well what do you do with it?
Does it sit in the garage?
- It sits in the garage! Let's be honest!
(laughs)
- That would be more
of a reason to sell it.
- That's what happens!
- If it was in your living room,
and you liked looking at it,
and thinking back to a brighter day,
then you should keep it.
Are you interested in selling it, or?
- How much do you want to give?
- As little as humanly possible.
- Of course.
- Yeah.
Three?
- Okay.
Nah I can't, thank you.
- Wanna go inside today?
(laughs)
- You should keep it.
But clean it up and put it in your house.
And enjoy it.
- [Resident] 10 bucks!
- I'd give you five max.
(inaudible)
- I can't do it, I'm sorry!
- No worries.
I'm actually proud of you.
Super well.
(old school-style hip hop music)
Have a great day.
- [Resident] Thank you guys.
(car door bell)
- How do you like my Mug
Life t-shirt, D-Rock?
(cash register)
Pretty good.
Thank you.
Pokemon cards.
Yeah, but
one of the great games
of all time, D-Rock.
Banana-fucking-grams.
You can use it as a phone stand, too.
Gary Vee, do I need good equipment?
No, motherfucker!
Use a banana peel!
How much are the pins?
- [Resident] Which ones?
- [Gary] All of 'em.
- [Resident] Two dollar each.
- [Gary] How much, how many?
- [Resident] Two dollars each.
- [Gary] Two dollar a piece.
- [Resident] That's my collection.
- [Gary] It's very cool.
It's a nice collection.
Yeah I don't like the Dolphins.
- [Resident] Two dollars.
- Yeah, I hate Dan Marino.
I hate Dan Marino, I'm a Jets fan.
- You don't like him?
- No, you?
- That's why I'm selling.
- That's right.
(laughs)
- [Resident] Three dollars,
two dollars.
(laughs)
- I would do a dollar for
it if you want to sell it.
- [Resident] Yeah it's fine.
- Okeedoke.
Whoops.
(cash register)
Thank you, brother.
Bye, guys, have a great day.
Bye bye, take care, my friend.
What's up, bro?
- [Man] I didn't wanna
(old school style hip hop music)
- [Gary] Blow up my spot?
- Yeah.
- How are you?
- Thank you so much.
- Yeah, man.
How's it goin' today?
Find anything?
- I just found a Playstation One.
- Let's go.
- For like $10 bucks.
- That's what's up.
How much do they go for?
- They go for like $40, $50.
- Love it.
- Thank you so much,
ah man, yo
- Don't worry.
- Thank you so much, man.
- What's your name?
- Tommy.
- Tommy, nice to meet you, bro.
- I watch all your stuff!
- Thank you bro.
Thank you, take care of yourself.
Stay well, keep hustling.
Got this retro Super Mario bag.
He wanted $3.
He didn't get it!
Paid a buck, like what!
A vlog, on YouTube.
- When my son pulled away, he said,
that's a YouTuber!
(laughs)
That's me, it's true!
How's the sale going today?
- [Resident] Good.
- [Resident] Pretty good!
- Getting rid of some stuff?
What are these?
- [D-Rock] I don't know.
- [Man] Sellin' the whole set.
(buzz)
Those are the guys!
That's them, we know those guys.
(laughs)
- We do?
- [Man] Yes!
We've seen them twice!
- I love it.
Straight?
- [Man] Yeah.
(laughs)
I know that fucking guy!
- I love it!
- I'm positive I know that guy.
You're out there.
And I know you.
- Hello.
- Hi.
- I'm interested in a
large lemonade, please.
- Okay.
Would you like ice?
- Please.
- Okay.
- A large lemonade is one dollar.
- Okay, can I give you
$20 for a large lemonade?
Is that allowed?
- Yeah.
- You cool with that?
(inaudible)
Thank you so much.
Keep the change.
- Oh thank you so much!
- You're welcome.
You're welcome.
Dirty.
- Hi.
- Are you Gary?
- I am. Can I have a picture with you?
- You can.
- My father's a big fan of you.
- Thank you.
- He's an entrepreneur.
- Tell him I said what's up.
But I live in New York.
- I hate to bother you,
I bumped into you earlier,
I was kinda losing my
mind, are you Gary Vee?
- I am.
- My God, it's a pleasure to meet you.
- Thank you.
- Mind if I get a picture?
- Sure.
Ready?
- Absolutely.
- Thank you.
- Awesome, nice to meet you.
- So sorry to bother you.
- I'm not bothered.
- Huge fan.
- Thank you, brother.
Awesome.
Nice meeting you guys.
Yep.
Hi.
- Hi, I'm Jackie.
- Nice to meet you, Jackie.
- Could you turn this on?
Thank you so much.
- Thank you so much for this.
- Three,
one, two, three.
Perfect.
- Awesome, nice meeting
you guys. Yeah, take care.
- [Man] Guys, good luck with your sale.
- Thank you.
You too.
Got it?
- [Man] Yeah, no he picked up a book
that he just found earlier.
One
for $600
- What?
Show me.
- Yeah.
(laughs)
- You found this book?
- [Man] He picked it up as a joke
for a brother.
- For a brother.
- Ah, it's listed for $600.
- $600.
- Have you seen 'sold'?
- Yeah I'm looking up right now.
- Awesome.
That's awesome, have fun, guys.
Take care.
I was about to punch him
and steal his book. (laughs)
Yo, before I go into the recap,
you know we got that Mug Life swag!
How 'bout this limited edition
out of only 500 t-shirts.
They'll be coming soon.
Details to come in the commentary.
Do we have links for this
yet? Are we sellin' 'em yet?
Limited edition Mug Life swag
coming soon, links in the
description in YouTube,
if we've got 'em.
Paid $3 bucks for this Christmas tree.
Paid $5 for this South
Park plush collection.
Paid $7 for this Skylanders collection.
Paid $8 for this vintage Budweiser light.
Paid a buck for this starlight Ferrari.
Paid $5 for these two vintage Yankee mugs.
Paid $2 for these Ugly Dolls.
(hip hop music)
Paid a buck for this
Super Mario vintage bag.
Paid a dollar for this vintage Popple.
How did this Popple work again?
It's Poppling, bro, this is nasty!
Look at this!
See what I just did?
Bang!
Popple!
Paid a dollar for this
vintage Wrinkle dog puppet.
He stole me!
(laughs)
Paid a dollar for this
vintage Garfield beanbag.
Bought these five mugs for five bucks.
Stole 'em.
'Cause it's fuckin' Mug Life out here.
Picked up this phone for $2 bucks.
Paid $2 dollars for this
vintage Cabbage Patch.
Paid a buck for this vintage Pound Puppy.
I love dogs
that I can flip.
(laughs)
Paid a buck for this mug.
Paid a buck for this
Disney Parks Haunted House
or Animal Kingdom mug.
Paid a buck for this Disney Parks
'It's A Small World' mug.
Paid a buck for this Disney mug.
Winnie The Pooh is always in play.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel!
right, Wrinkle?
Right!
(hip hop music)
♪ Started today ♪
♪ Life is what you make ♪
♪ Make it what you like ♪
♪ It's your choice, it's your voice ♪
♪ You only got one ♪
♪ Make it count, baby ♪